there is new fallout from prince harry
and meghan markle's incendiary interview
with oprah
it aired in the uk for the first time
last night to a sharply divided response
the headlines the headlines in the
papers this morning described the worst
crisis
for the british monarchy in decades and
some of the same tabloids that harry and
megan blame in part for their departure
continue to criticize him right now
harry and megan's allegations of racism
are raising the stakes and how this all
plays out along with questions about the
monarchy's handling of mental health
holly williams is outside buckingham
palace for us holly good morning to you
any response yet
good morning well it's been almost a day
and a half since the interview aired in
the u.s
12 million people watched on television
here last night
in a country of less than 7 of just
under 17 million
we've still had no comment from
buckingham palace but one of megan's
family members
has been speaking out when they decided
to talk to me i'll stop talking to the
press
it's being seen as a real attack on the
monarchy
driven by your daughter britain woke up
this morning to find
thomas markle on television he's megan's
father
the same man who handed over a letter
from his daughter
to a british tabloid newspaper
interviewed by piers morgan
former tabloid editor they went way over
the top
with these stories with oprah
and should have waited considering
considering that
the the queen's age harry and megan
claim
one factor that drove them to america in
the first place
was the british tabloid media with that
relationship
and that that control and the fear by
the
by the uh by the uk um tabloids it's a
really
it's a toxic environment an environment
the duchess says drove her to
contemplate
suicide but for the royal family the
most explosive
most damaging allegation was that at
least one member of the family had
concerns about the color of their son's
skin
there are several conversations there's
a conversation
with you with harry about
how dark your baby is going to be
potentially and what that would mean or
look like
oprah says harry told her it wasn't the
queen or her husband
prince philip something journalist afiya
adam told us the accusation of racism
at the very pinnacle of british society
is
hurtful well i didn't expect for the
racism
to be so blatant and so insidious and so
systemic
but let's be honest we have this kind of
racism in britain
i shouldn't have been surprised but will
this bombshell interview spark a change
or even renew a debate in this country
about racism and the power wielded by
britain's tabloid media
the british media is reporting this
morning that the royal family has been
holding
crisis talks following harry and megan's
interview
anthony ollie williams at buckingham
palace in london thank you holly